hi guys and welcome back to city
skylines today we are going to work on
the city a bit more and as you can see
well I always do this of course I was
playing a game don't judge me I was just
trying to look at the downtown which was
pretty nice and that I still had this
area next to the river bank and I was
like yeah I I'm just going to add some
houses to that because I have nothing
else to add to that really and as you
can tell by my demand by people did not
want houses of people want commercial
areas and people want industries but
silver at doesn't care he only cares
about the way that his city looks I I
suppose that's a good way to put it
though that's really not the case per se
anessa in this sense I do of course also
want my city to function well and there
is nothing i can't stand more than damn
traffic piling up in my streets are not
suitably something i want to avoid but
the looks of the city is so much more
important to me than building the most
efficient city ever on a perfect grid
and with beautiful beautiful public
transport there are so many people
already doing that and actually failing
and it's when they're trying to make and
we sitting like that and that's kind of
funny i think but this city is all about
organic growth so yeah I kind of want to
make it a city look realistic look cool
but it's probably a bit better than in
real life because real life cities don't
have this many parks real life city is
also going to have an employment rate of
one hundred percent with an education
level of university or higher for most
of the people in the city but that
doesn't matter this I suppose this is
also kind of a utopia in some ways
except for the weird industries and
other somewhat unrealistic things at the
moment which will be fixed in the future
I'll promise that but yeah I do like my
cities in an organic growth so add
that's something to know about me that
is something that I am aiming to do in
the future and also organic growth means
European organic growth and that means
well curvy roads and stuff like that I
can already hear you say but the suburbs
also have curvy roads silver at you do
not know anything about the ameri
can life I do I i do care about
Americans but you know I want to have
those European curvy roads you could say
i love my rose like a lot i'm actually
and i'm not even gonna say that but i'm
also going to have the slightly curvy
and cooked roads in the downtown areas
and in the industrial areas and
everywhere and the overall growth of the
city is going to be like that because
even though sub urban areas in America
do have that very often they're also
commonly cities in America commonly have
straight borders and stuff like that
which is actually something you
sometimes see in the city layouts and
even though the suburbs have very curly
rotze the cities themselves or obviously
don't really most of the times so the
city does have that so there is a big
difference now another thing that I did
want is not just an organic growth road
pattern but also an organic growth
pattern are as there is a extreme
emphasis on the pronunciation there
because it is growth and I kind of want
this city to be a bit round like that
and in the future if I get the land that
is I also want to have some cities
around this may be some small cluster
cities actually turn this into a kind of
group of multiple cities of course
they're having that big one city in the
middle but there is no such thing as a
huge standalone city with a downtown and
Mary ha many highways around it and all
that and not having any cities next to
that you're obviously gonna want to have
some small towns and other things around
this so definitely going to work on this
oh and this this is when i add the
highway next to the Hague i think this
is still called no way da was already
gone but people are already mad because
i have that one lane highway but now
it's it's a huge highway just a
full-grown highway and people are very
mad in Dallas and Indianapolis
indianapolis right now and the land view
values are dropping very quickly but i
don't care i want all this transport to
be possible
you see all those colored trucks going
to the city center that was no no it was
definitely not what was supposed to
happen I don't know what the where these
trucks are exactly coming from because
they seem to be coming from many
industrial areas throughout the city but
I do want to keep them out of the city
so at some point I was like no this is
not going to happen so actually rather
than adding highways sometimes it works
to remove highways so that people are
forced to just do the stuff on other
highways because this highway going into
them well center of the city if you may
call it that it's supposed to be used by
people who live in the city and want to
move in the city and not stupid trucks
who think that the city is their realm
the industrial zone is their realm and
the highway around that is their realm
but not the city itself you definitely
want to keep the industrial traffic and
the residential and commercial traffic
very divided like that you definitely
don't want to have them in one spot so
and what I meant by deleting highways is
very simply deleting off ramps if you
don't want your people to get into the
city or on the highway or of the highway
at a certain spot you just delete the
off-ramp I suppose I think I figured
that would work and I was afraid that
wouldn't work and that they would turn
around on the nearest off-ramp but that
didn't actually work that didn't
actually happen I mean so in the end the
trucks are now using different highways
and not causing too many problems in the
center of the city so that's fine and
dandy of course there's still kind of
causing problems in the industrial areas
but yeah whatever those are the
industrial areas so nobody nobody really
cares about that and as you can see work
continues on the areas around the city
because there is demand for homes and I
want to have a bigger population because
I want to get all the goals and
achievements and the steam levels so
definitely wanted to work on that now up
coming here is what i like to call the
turtle which is the most beautiful
residential area you have ever seen
witnessed in a city ever it is literally
designed after a turtle I'm very much
that this is going to ruin my reputation
of the silver and who actually does the
curvy European roads because I have
never actually seen a total road pattern
in my entire life lots of vote not
really sure what I was actually supposed
to do and it wasn't actually planned
either I just kind of looped around it
because you know I was restricted by the
highways around that area and then i
went back and i divided the area in more
roads so that i would have more grids
and more building space and then it
turned out to look like her to like a
turtle that just came out of nowhere it
must have been my unconscious doing that
and this area is going to be the
commercial area because the great moment
has arrived I have deleted the parks in
my city and as you can see there is a
sudden spike in the commercial again so
I place that over there and I am
actually not really sure what that road
pattern is a bit supposed to be like
it's kind of like a woven kind of thing
not really sure but I was like yeah I
have so many road patterns in my city
there are so curvy and round and do all
of these crazy things you just need to
have some normal roads you just need to
have some decency sometimes so I built
some normal roads because this is this
is also a commercial area after all and
then I did something stupid that I did
what nobody should ever do and I should
know this but I still did it because I
was stupid at the time is and this this
goes for any city building game so I've
no idea why I did that but if you have
demand for something don't go crazy and
built an entire metropolis out of just
that one zone which you have demand for
because that is not going to work if you
have a lot of commercial demand just
slowly gradually build it up place a
couple things and then just let it rest
them I people do their things and see if
there is still demand because otherwise
you're gonna have to have either empty
lots or you're going to have companies
that can't sell their goods and then
they're going to be destroyed are you
gonna end up with empty lots too so that
that is the inevitable death of a zone
which does not have demand because you
over placed it so
never do that this is a advice from the
silver also advice from silver at what
you can see me doing our is saying oh
well I have that one little traffic
intersection over there which is causing
some terrible congestion I will just
remove part of it and move the other
part of it to a different part of that
road and that was stupid and definitely
not necessary because if there's one
thing to learn it is that you don't fix
traffic problems by just saying well I'm
just going to add a small little road
over here or you know I'm just gonna add
extra lanes to this road that definitely
does not work you're going to have to
either change the whole road layout of
the area or you have going to have to
provide more public services like buses
and metro system or a train stop like
that or you're gonna have to do
something even bigger in the grand scale
of things you're gonna have to change
where people live and stuff like that
but that goes too far just for one big
area just for one small area where
there's congestion even even I at some
point and sometimes just wondering like
why would I even bother seriously why
would even bother with congestion it's
not really causing any problems that man
I mean it looks ugly but then again is
it really bad for my city yes kind of it
is kind of bad in when it especially in
real life and I'm pretty sure there
should be calculated in city skylines as
well now this little neat thing in the
highway is where you add another section
of the highway work I don't even it's
hard to explain but you basically
duplicate part of the highway so that
people from another highway can get in
over there and then later on get on that
other highway so they don't have to get
from one highway to another in one go
but there is like this kind of highway
in between that code that means that it
doesn't cause all those problems with
traffic jams and stuff like that but
people can just slowly but surely go on
the highway that everybody wants to be
and I suppose that those kind of work
it's not really the best looking thing
but sometimes if one part of a highway
of one-off off or on ramp is
very commonly used it doesn't just fix
it by making that on off ramp a highway
and actually adding a couple of lanes
because that means if it's that commonly
used it's also going to block the
traffic that wants to just go on on the
other highway that it's trying to join
so you're gonna have to add that
separate kind of thing and that kind of
does work but that didn't really solve
the problem at least from where it was
coming because as it turned out the
because i figured when I was making
these industrial things that I was very
smart by not adding a connection between
the two industrial zones right away
because that would mean more traffic
lights I'm traffic lights actually
because I don't have any at the moment
that would mean more intersections and
more traffic jams and stuff like that
but instead if trucks had to go from one
industrial area to another they had to
go in the highway and drive around for a
bit then go to the nearest interchange
and get on another highway and drive
around on that for a bit and get another
interchange to loop all the way back to
the other industrial area and that was a
terrible idea so stuff like that you can
fix by just adding one small ramp so if
you can do that because sometimes
problems are just so obvious you just
don't see them and then you start coming
up with these stupid solutions that
aren't really solutions but you're only
making matters worse and this was kind
of a example of that but I've glad at
least that I fixed it in this video and
then I noticed it myself because
otherwise you know you're gonna have
that same problem where it turns out oh
no silver right you did this wrong and I
know you guys are trying to help me but
then again it was recorded earlier on
and right now this city is a complete
cluster [ __ ] when it comes to the
highways but yeah am I going to say no
I'm not going to say today this is it I
have nothing else to say and I've
nothing else to show so I'm going to see
you on the next episode thank you for
watching